is a book as old as the Bible relevant
for the modern business owner and
YouTube content creator Ecclesiastes 11
6 says this plant your seed in the
morning and keep busy all afternoon for
you don't know if profit will come from
one activity or the other or maybe both
the video that you spend 10 hours
editing that you make the perfect title
the best thumbnail and you're like this
is the one that one might fall flat and
get no views and then you like shoot a
video on your phone you just upload that
thing and all of a sudden that video
goes viral and you're like wow I had no
idea and so ultimately it's this
powerful principle that too many people
I've noticed get stuck over thinking
when really instead they need to just
start taking massive action